I have tons of inflammation, not sure if it's due to chemo pills or mistletoe, but I'm having tons of pain.
Except the day after the IV, the vitamin C, intuition.
I have liposol to curve clear on hand.
If I take that internally with that help, if so, how much?
This chemo pill, I can't hardly take the green's first shake, any ideas.
I have to have a PET scan, the doctor wants a baseline.
Are there any supplements that I should discontinue before the scan?
Last question first, no, there's nothing you should discontinue before the scan.
I would go ahead and get the scan. I think that would be good to see what's going on.
I know that chemo changes your taste buds.
It really changes your taste buds from a neurological perspective.
So, therefore, some things just don't taste well, but you don't feel good taking them.
And eating, that's a problem.
I understand that to give you any ideas, try to change the taste by adding other things to it.
Chocolate, I don't know, something like that.
Focal powder, give me a different taste.
That would be a nice suggestion.
The liposol will curcuclear with that be good to decrease inflammation.
So, what would be good to decrease inflammation are different flavonoids.
So, curcumin, yes, the liposol will curcuclear with be good.
How much should you take in that?
Well, you know, really, you really can't take too much of it.
You really want to get a high dose in to decrease inflammation, but it can be good.
If you have some other flavonoids at home, too, to have those on hand, too,
because it can be kind of a synergistic effect if you use other flavonoids, too.
Like Boswellia, EGCG from Green Tea Extract can be helpful.
The barks, like pine bark extract can be helpful.
Corsitant can be helpful.
Gropalate, which is an enzyme, but it can be helpful.
Gropalate which is the product from Beats, which the Alvia created,
that is very helpful for some people with pain.
Two, that is called Limitless by alvia.
very helpful. That's helped a lot of people with pain, CBD, THC. Those are all the things
that you think of to decrease inflammation or to decrease pain.